All of us are moving towards
more virtual communication.
That is a shift in context that's going to
change the way people understand you,
the way people experience you.
You cannot engage in exactly
the same behavior and
assume that you're going to get exactly
the same results, the context shifts.
>> It's been more than a year since we
went from spending time in meeting rooms
and long commutes, to meeting over
Zooms and accidentally staying on mute.
As GSB Associate Dean Brian Lowry
just implied, we need to adjust our
communication and presence to make
sure we get the results we want.
My name is Matt Abrahams, and
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to this quick thinks episode
of Think Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
In this episode, we're bringing
you some of the best advice we've
received from guests on how to be more
successful in your professional and
personal life when
communicating virtually.
Attention is the most valuable
commodity we have in the world today.
More valuable than money,
more valuable than Bitcoin, and
even more valuable than GameStop stock.
When communicating virtually,
you need to work hard to both gain and
maintain attention and focus.
It's all about being relevant and
engaging.
Here are a few tips from
Professors Tina Seelig, Bob Sutton,
and Sara Sual on how to keep
your audience interested.
>> I think it's really important to
change up activities really quickly,
like every 10 to 15 minutes.
I almost feel it's almost
like Sesame Street.
Every 10 to 15 minutes you need to change.
Watching a video, to doing an activity,
to breaking into small groups.
Folks get bored looking at
a screen if things are static, so
you need to plan a lot in advance.
I view myself as more of a producer
when I'm planning an online class.
There's a tremendous amount of thought
that goes into essentially scripting
the whole experience.
[MUSIC]
>> I think we're all struggling
in this journey together.
The first thing that I
would start out with, and
this is for those of us who are teachers,
who are executives, and also just
having control of our calendar, is that
for emotional and cognitive reasons,
we've got to pace ourselves and
encourage people to pace one another.
So this means the meetings
have to be shorter.
This means there has to be breaks.
This means, and some of the folks at the
design school are really cool about this,
consider doing 35% of
your meetings audio only.
[MUSIC]
>> So as educators, I think we have to
find ways to reduce cognitive overload.
So, for example, I now offer my
information in much smaller pieces.
Interpersed with breakout groups or
synchronous work and share documents,
that's one of the tricks that
I've been experimenting with.
I've also been working to make my
slides more visually appealing and
much less cluttered.
And this is where I've had the opportunity
to watch you teach frequently on slide
design, and
this has been very helpful to me.
>> Well, thank you.
Presence is also critical to success
when communicating virtually.
We need to be able to authentically
connect to our audiences,
not just through our words, but
also through our nonverbal behaviors.
Here are my favorite quick
tips from Carol Robbins,
Professors Christian Wheeler and Jennifer
Aaker, and lecturer, Naomi Bagdonis.
On how simple and
slight shifts in your presence can
help you connect more authentically
with your remote audiences.
>> The fact is that I
think we've become much
more transactional as
a result of the pandemic.
And much more task-oriented, especially in
business, at the expense of relationships.
So we have a lot of contact, maybe,
but not a whole lot of connection.
And if we want more connection, then
we've gotta make a little bit of time to
ask each other, how are you really doing?
[MUSIC]
>> One thing that organizations need to
think about is ways to artificially induce
that into this more formal Zoom-style
interaction that we've adopted.
So in my exercises, what we do is we have
people engage in exercises where they're
interacting with one another.
They're experiencing this positive ethic,
and they're engaging in some degree of
self-disclosure, which is something
that creates the foundations of trust.
[MUSIC]
>> It used to be that leaders
needed to be revered, and
now they need to be understood.
And all the while, humor is
a particularly potent elixir for trust.
And when we laugh with someone, be it in
person or even over screens through Zoom.
The bottom line, Matt,
is giving birth, having sex, and
laughing with colleagues in Zoom
meetings actually have a lot in common.
We're building trust and
no one's wearing pants.
>> [LAUGH] There you go.
[MUSIC]
Technology has allowed us to
connect like never before, as so
many of us work from home.
But as we all know, technology can really
make or break how we're perceived and
how we get our messages across.
Use these straightforward tips
that I share with my students
when you use Zoom, Teams, Meet,
or any other virtual tool.
How you show up really matters.
Make sure you fill up half the screen
with your face and upper body.
Make sure there's a little bit of room
between your head and the top of your box.
Check this out before you
actually join the meeting.
You have to be well lit, too.
As human beings,
we read a lot on people's faces.
And if we can't see your face, if you're
covered in the shadows like you're in
the witness protection program,
it makes it hard for us to trust you.
Be well lit and fill up the screen.
You also need to make sure you raise your
camera up so it's right at your eye level.
So it looks like we're looking directly
at you when you're speaking to us.
And make sure you look at that camera so
it looks like you're looking
at us as we're watching you.
Making eye contact is critical for
building connection and trust.
I take a picture of my family,
who on most days I like,
and I tape it right behind my camera.
So I'm looking at people I
care about as I present.
That draws my attention to the camera,
and can be really helpful for connecting.
Variation is also critical in your voice.
If people are monotone or their rate stays
the same, we lose focus and attention.
We're designed to pay attention to
things that change and vary, so
make sure you vary your voice.
A great way to do this is to add emotive
words, adjectives, adverbs, descriptors.
We tend to inflect our
voice as we say those.
Make sure also that you gesture.
Now, gestures are different
when you're virtual.
You need to make sure your hands
are up and visible in the box.
That means keeping your thumbs
about at your shoulder height.
And always make sure to gesture
slightly beyond your shoulders, not so
far that you go out of your box.
But you don't want your gestures
in front of your face or
your chest,
it makes you look tense and tight.
Finally, when managing interaction,
like conversation during a meeting or
during a Q&A session,
leverage paraphrasing.
Paraphrasing is a tool that helps
you signal that you've heard what
somebody said.
But it also allows you to interrupt and
interject, simply highlight or
summarize something somebody has said.
And then add your opinion and
link or bridge to the next topic.
Taken together, working on engagement,
presence, and how you can maximize
your remote tools set up, you can enhance
and hone your virtual communication.
Taking the time to work on these
skills will serve you well.
Because while we're all excited to return
to more in-person communication and
interaction, virtual communication
is likely here to stay.
Thanks for joining us for another episode
of Think Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
Produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business.
For more information and
episodes, visit gsb.stanford.edu.
Find us on social media, @stanford.gsb.